Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When we are talking about deep learning, we
are talking about neural networks that have
tens, sometimes hundreds of layers, and hundreds
of neurons within these layers.
This is an enormous number of parameters to
train, and clearly, there should be some redundancy,
some duplication in the information within.
This paper is trying to throw out many of
these neurons of the network without affecting
its accuracy too much.
This process we shall call pruning and it
helps creating neural networks that are faster
and smaller.
The accuracy term I used typically means a
score on a classification task, in other words,
how good this learning algorithm is in telling
what an image or video depicts.
This particular technique is specialized for
pruning Convolutional Neural Networks, where
the neurons are endowed with a small receptive
field and are better suited for images.
These neurons are also commonly referred to
as filters.
So here, we have to provide a good mathematical
definition of a proper pruning.
The authors proposed a definition where we
can specify a maximum accuracy drop that we
deem to be acceptable, which will be denoted
with the letter "b" in a moment.
And the goal is to prune as many filters as
we can, without going over the specified accuracy
loss budget.
The pruning process is controlled by an accuracy
and efficiency term, and the goal is to have
some sort of balance between the two.
To get a more visual understanding of what
is happening, here, the filters you see outlined
with the red border are kept by the algorithm,
and the rest are discarded.
As you can see, the algorithm is not as trivial
as many previous approaches that just prune
away filters with weaker responses.
Here you see the table with the b numbers.
Initial tests reveal that around a quarter
of the filters can be pruned with an accuracy
loss of 0.3%, and with a higher b, we can
prune more than 75% of the filters with a
loss of around 3%.
This is incredible.
Image segmentation tasks are about finding
the regions that different objects inhabit.
Interestingly, when trying the pruning for
this task, it not only introduces a minimal
loss of accuracy, in some cases, the pruned
version of the neural network performs even
better.
How cool is that!
And of course, the best part is that we can
choose a tradeoff that is appropriate for
our application.
For instance, if we are we looking for a light
cleanup, we can use the first option at a
minimal penalty, or, if we wish to have a
tiny tiny neural network that can run on a
mobile device, we can look for the more heavy-handed
approach by sacrificing just a tiny bit more
accuracy.
And, we have everything in between.
There is plenty more validation for the method
in the paper, make sure to have a look!
It is really great to see that new research
works make neural networks not only more powerful
over time, but there are efforts in making
them smaller and more efficient at the same
time.
Great news indeed.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!